Jud appow this is a weird connection I'm
G tell you all about this guy but he
grew up in saset so when we were at NBC
that's on Long Island you called me up
and asked me for an interview I think as
someone's friend worked at NBC and
somehow wrangled the favor yeah and what
did you do you had a little radio show
or something well I wanted to be a comic
you know so I was a dishwasher at East
Side comedy club in Huntington because I
wanted to be a comedian how old were you
when you interviewed me I was 15 someone
must have pressured you into you know I
would lie to everybody and act like my
high school radio station was a real
station so I would call up Leno's
publicist and go would Jay like to do an
interview for WK wz out on Long Island
Jay do anything and then I would show up
and then Jay would see this kid with
this enormous AV Squad tape recorder and
he'd be like ah [__] I got to do this
and then I would ask him how to be a
comedian and then I tried to be a
comedian so on your Dopey Radio Show in
high school you had Seinfeld and Leno
yeah everybody for like an hour I had
like John Candy and Steve Allen and
Guido Sardi I was like a it was like I
was a lunatic I was just hunting
everyone down but I only gave you 5
minutes I blew you off right I thought
it was the nicest thing ever but you you
would gave me about 4 minutes and uh I
respected that like I couldn't believe I
got 10 seconds this is Jud as a
15-year-old at sasan high school it's
got to be 802 the ear 82 and this is uh
listen to the Long Island accent from
who you from me and this maybe before
the voice really changed hi Jud yes hi
Mr s yeah hi how are you I'll just go
right into it because I we're pretty
tight on time um what is uh the
philosophy of your show right now you
seem to have a pretty wild show it seems
to be getting uh looser and looser yeah
as time get looser and looser it's going
to get even looser yeah more wild we're
just being ourselves on the air that's
the philosophy of the show be yourself
on the air and get real weird what kind
of you know arguments you get in with
the NBC people about what you're allowed
to say because they always have all
these rules and regulations but
you know when I get on the air I start I
think my eyes start to roll into the
back of my head and I blank out I don't
take any responsibility for what I say
um and like the other week you got in
trouble for burping on the yeah I got I
got chastised I didn't get suspended
though they just said it to you they
don't want me to burp on the air you you
sound like you're
rushing you know like you're thr what's
your philosophy just go crazy don't go
wild I didn't know the guy would grow up
and be somebody I just I'm just shocked
that you ever burped in the air that's
shocking you were really doing a cutting
Ed Show at that point it was never heard
of actually you just didn't do that kind
of
stuff